[Music]
get it up
you talk about putting up in your Getty
that's it you talk about a night on the
town drinking your hand I gotta ask you
I think I have an idea but what is your
favorite drink when you're going out
[Music]
party or I just want to
like I was gonna say you're a spicy Mark
you're giving feisty bark because I'm a
spicy Mark guy so I feel like I'm vibing
with you right now it's a spicy Mark but
it is I like it I like the hot not too
not too sweet not too spicy and that's
me I am definitely not too sweet I'm a
little rough around the edges if you
have a couple spicy marks are you a good
dancer
else
because that choreo in the video for
Giddy Up was was a little wild I know
you hit it can you do that I'm not a
great dancer I really am not I have
great Rhythm okay um I was never a great
dancer like I'm a great mover I can move
I'm athletic okay well it's objective
it's objective it is because I've Got
Rhythm and I'm athletic there you go so
you can dance so that makes a good dance
you can dance let's go come on
[Music]